oh thank you for stopping everyone acts
like nothing's wrong like my little boy
isn't please you have to help me get my
little Tucker but don't you tell me to
calm down he ran out into the wilderness
a few days ago I warned him oh lord
please well I guess I can't ask you I
got some bits saved up for a rainy day
I'll give you thank you look for him in
amber Heights you hear it's down the
road southwest of town I'm and if you
find any of them iconoclast and duck
y'see concentrated amount of skull and
present okay you reckon I smell never
goes away maybe don't
[Music]
[Applause]
this area has been sanitized
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
you
well hello and welcome to the home of
the iconic in it you'll find oh no I'm
so why no corporate oh those are just
you welcome the new boy
yes last I saw him he was seems like a
nice little town except for all them
dead critters yeah
making blood-stained clean again looks
like I'm not the only new face around
here what do I call you straight welcome
to Aunt you here to join the I I am NOT
a little boy haven't been one for
decades no matter what my mama wishes I
take it she still according to her
stepping foot out don't go play with
friends I stuck around way too long
captain
yeah what what in the nebula is wrong
with you she's
you are real sick
you
Oh captain you so grateful captain and
don't worry I'm never leaving mama alone
she'll be very safe from anyone who
wants to hurt her
what a strange thing to say well yes
here kind stranger this is every bit I